you know some of our best work come from
like leaks and rumors and unfortunately
you know I hate you know that you know
Insomniac some of the you know personal
data happens you know but there's human
beings who get docked all the time and
don't get the same level of care um so
you know I do feel for them on that you
know what I mean and you know their hard
work you know being put out like that
but at we got to be consistent if we're
going to have that attitude then you
know let's not report on on leaks period
let's not spoil things remember you know
Jeff key didn't mind spoiling the price
of the Xbox One X back in 2017 an hour
before they uh showed off the console um
like this stuff happens all the time
it's just the energy is different
depending on who who it is and I think
um the industry journalists you know
content creative we got to be consistent
you know what's what's right what's
wrong and what are we going to report um